WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH THE
FBI.
BUY WE'RE GOING TO REBUILD
THE FBI.
IT WILL BE BIGGER AND BETTER
THAN EVER.
BUT IT IS VERY SAD WHEN YOU
PEOPLE THAT ARE SEEING IT.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT.
AND I'M GOING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE FBI.
THEIR NEW BUILDING.
TO THE FBI IS CERTAINLY VERY
PRESIDENT EARLIER TODAY
BEFORE HE DEPARTED FOR THE
FBI'S NATIONAL ACADEMY IN
QUANTICO, VIRGINIA WHERE HE
SPOKE AT A GRADUATION
CEREMONY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS FOR THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND AROUND
THE WORLD.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHTFULLY
UPSET WITH SOME OF THE
BLATANT BIAS BEING SHOWN BY
TOP RANKING OFFICIALS, NOT
RANK AND FILE AT THE FBI AND
THE DOJ.
THOSE MEN AND WOMEN OF LAW
PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE.
AND WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT
FEELS THE SAME WAY.
>> IT'S AN HONOR TO STAND
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I AM HERE.
BUT TO HONOR YOU FOR YOUR
COURAGE AND YOUR DEVOTION.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WITH
ME AS YOUR PRESIDENT
AMERICA'S POLICE WILL HAVE A
MORE LOYAL THAN ANYONE ELSE
SECURITY ANALYST.
AND INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER
SARAH CARTER.
IT'S SO SAD BECAUSE IF YOU
THOSE HA WORK HARD.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE THE HEAD
OF THE FBI.
JAMES COMEY, WORKING WITH
PETER STRZOK.
AND THEY ARE RIDING.
THAT'S NOT EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW.
PETER STRZOK WHO THINKS FOR
SOME REEL REASON GOD
APPOINTED HIM TO SAVE THE
COUNTRY AND THAT THEY ARE
BUILDING INSURANCE POLICIES
IN CASE TRUMP WINS, THIS IS
CORRUPTION, I THINK, AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL WE HAVE EVER
SEEN.
YOUR REACTION?
>> WELL, YEAH.
I MEAN, I AM TALKING TO
FIELD AGENTS TODAY.
A NUMBER OF FIELD AGENTS.
AND RETIRED FBI AGENTS.
AND THEY HAVE THE SAME
SENTIMENT AS PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
REMEMBER, PEOPLE WANT TO
CRITICIZE PRESIDENT TRUMP
BUT WHAT WE HAVE SEEN ON THE
BEFORE.
PEOPLE HAVE SAID THIS OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
NEVER SEEN THIS TYPE OF
AND YOU KNOW, SEAN, WHAT WAS
EVEN MORE INTERESTING TO ME
WAS THEY WERE TELLING ME
THEY WERE AT AN EVENT.
ALL OF THESE FIELD AGENTS
EVERYBODY WAS WORRIED ABOUT
RUSSIA COLLUSION WITH TRUMP.
INSTEAD WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
FBI SEVENTH FLOOR COLLUSION
WITH CLINTON.
AND THAT'S HOW THEY ARE
FEELING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SEBASTIAN, GORKA, I KNOW HOW
YOU FEEL ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WE ALL FEEL THE SAME WAY.
BUT THIS IS REAL COLLUSION.
THIS IS REAL CORRUPTION.
FOR.
DID HE HIS INVESTIGATION.
TO ME, IF I'M JAMES COMEY
TONIGHT, EACH PETER STRZOK
TONIGHT.
I'M THINKING I BETTER HIRE
THE BEST LAWYERS D.C. HAS.
>> SEAN, SARAH IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
I HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH
THOUSANDS OF AGENTS AND
ANALYSTS.
I WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
EARLIER THIS WEEK FOR THE
CHRISTMAS CELEBRATIONS.
AND SO WAS ANOTHER RETIRED
AGENT FROM THE FBI WHO HAD
AT LEAST 20, 25 YEARS IN.
HE RECOGNIZED ME.
CAME UP TO ME AND HE SAID,
THE BUREAU'S REPUTATION IS
SHOT.
AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROTECTING US
ON THE STREETS IN THE
TERRORISM TASK FORCES.
IT'S BECAUSE OF A HANDFUL OF
BAD APPLES.
THE BENT COPS, CORRUPT COPS.
SEAN, THE SADDEST THING IS,
WE ARE GETTING THE DOCUMENTS
COLLUSION INSIDE THE FBI TO
SHE IS THE NEXT PRESIDENT.
THE CC LINE, I'M SEEING
NAMES OF AGENTS I HIGHLY
RESPECTED AND HAVE WORKED
WITH WHO ONCE THEY GOT TO
THE SEVENTH FLOOR, SEAN
THAT'S IT UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THEY BECAME
TO REBUILD THE FBI.
BUT, THE PRESIDENT SAID IT
TODAY, HE IS GOING TO
REBUILD IT.
AND HE CAN REBUILD IT.
>> Sean: IT NEEDS TO BE
REBUILT.
AND THE SAME BY THE WAY TOP
PEOPLE, FORMER OBAMA PEOPLE
WITHIN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY BEFORE THIS WAS
ALL SAID AND DONE.
I BELIEVE THIS HOUSE OF
CARDS FALLS.
YOU KNOW, YOUR STORY
YESTERDAY ABOUT REVERSE
TARGETING THE MISQULIEWFS
THE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE THAT WE GIVE
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
THAT YOU REPORTED, SARAH,
THAT DOESN'T EVEN GET INTO
THE DOSSIER ISSUE.
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY
HILLARY WITH SALACIOUS
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA LIES TO
URANIUM ONE DEAL.
I'M NOT SURE HOW WE UNTANGLE
ALL OF THIS IN THE BEST WAY
TO DO THAT.  YOUR THOUGHTS
ON IT?
>> WELL, I THINK THE BEST
WAY TO DO THAT IS ONE STEP
AT A TIME.
ONE STORY AT A TIME, SEAN,
ONE INVESTIGATION AT A TIME.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE DONE
OVER THE PAST YEAR.
AND THAT'S WHY WE SEE THIS
YARN UNRAVELING, PEELING
BACK THE ONION AS YOU ALWAYS
SAY.
ONE LAYER AT A TIME.
AND NOW WITH, YOU BROUGHT UP
THE DOSSIER.
SUCH A GREAT POINT.
AND WE SEE NOW THAT BRUCE
OHR'S WIFE WAS HIRED BY
FUSION GPS TO HELP WITH THIS
DOSSIER.
I MEAN, THIS IS INCREDIBLE
STUFF.
WE WOULD HAVE NEVER
DISCOVERED THIS HAD WE NOT
DONE IT ONE STORY AT A TIME.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THAT.
BE VERY FACTUAL.
SO THAT THEY KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON AND SO THAT WE CAN
CLEAN UP OUR SYSTEM.
BECAUSE THIS IS STILL THE
GREATEST COUNTRY ON EARTH.
>> IF INTELLIGENCE IS
MISUSED AND PEOPLE ARE
PAYING PEOPLE FOR STORIES.
IF DOSSIERS FROM RUSSIA ARE
BEING USED.
IF, YOU KNOW, THE MISUSE OF
INTELLIGENCE.
IF LITERALLY WE ARE IGNORING
BRIANRY KICKS BACKS AND
URANIUM AWAY.
NONE OF THIS STEAMS TO COME
TO FULL RESOLUTION,
DR. GORKA.
OH, IT WILL.
STORIES ARE COMING OUT
THANKS TO SARAH AND JOHN AND
YOU --
>> Sean: AND YOU.
>> NO, NO.
THEY ARE DOING THE HEAVY
LIFTING AND YOU ARE.
SARAH IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
SHE STOLE MY THUNDER.
WE ARE THE GREATEST NATION
ON GOD'S EARTH WE ARE ALSO
THE MOST POWERFUL NATION ON
GOD'S EARTH.
WHICH MEANS WHEN YOU START
TO WEAPONIZE LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHEN YOU STARTED TO
POLITICALLY WEAPONIZE
INTELLIGENT COMMUNITY LIKE
JOHN BRENNAN.
LAST CREATION U ERIC HOLDER
DID.
IT IS MORE DANGEROUS THAN
ANYTHING YOU CAN IMAGINE.
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO
STEP IN NOW.
PEOPLE HAVE TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
>> Sean: THAT SEPARATES US
FROM A POLICE STATE.
THE DEEP STATE.
ILLEGALLY SURVEYING